it's fair to say but everyone in our
house absolutely adores picnics and not
just the kids tana and I love them as
well
so get ready for six perfect portable
dishes here's my ultimate picnic food
first such an egg roll into one in my
Twist on a favorite picnic breakfast
Scotch eggs
they're great don't they've got Ang
grenades a wonderful picnic lunch of
spiced carrot cumin and orange salad I
can't really ask much more from a carrot
can you
and a giant Mediterranean sandwich to
feed an entire family who would not want
to join you on a picnic with a sandwich
like that and where there's chocolate
and marshmallows Tilly is never far away
marshmallow my favorite
for our picnic tea she's getting stuck
in with a sticky chocolate marshmallow
and peanut fridge cake
a splendid Seaside anchovy dip with
crudites and a prawn and cucumber salad
with a spicy yogurt dressing come on
it's a bit like a tummy
see
three amazing movable feasts to keep
your family and friends energized for
Alfresco fun through breakfast lunch and
dinner
first up the perfect picnic breakfast My
ultimate Scotch eggs with a Twist
[Music]
I go fishing a lot and Scotch eggs are
the perfect all-in-one mini picnic
breakfast first thing get your eggs
cooked bring the water up the ball onto
the spoon and lower them into the water
that way they don't hit the water and
crack four and a half minutes that'll
keep the center nice
slightly running now ground sausage meat
I'm going to make mine a little bit
spicier I'm going to crumble in black
pudding that helps to season Scotch eggs
inside a little touch of salt and pepper
and then just to make it a little bit
sweeter and a lot easier for the kids to
eat some grated Apple
combine that blend in the apple and the
black pudding eggs once they're cooked
drain them and then run them under cold
water
cracking and cooling the eggs quickly
will prevent the yolks turning gray
tap them on the side of the pan
put them back into the water and what
happens the water seeps underneath the
shell
see the shell come off so much easier
eggs still slightly soft in the center I
want that little bit of richness for the
yolk next you need to get yourself
organized with a mini assembly line
seasoned flour
a little egg wash
and breadcrumbs take your mince golf
ball size
spread the Pate manipulate with your
thumb and then sit your egg in there
spread the sausage over the egg
and you just seal that over
really important to keep that nice even
coating of sausage meat around the egg
you don't want it too thick otherwise it
gets too dense and it's unappetizing
give them a light dusting in the
seasoned flour
if you don't put the flour on the egg
wash won't stick if you don't put the
egg wash on the breadcrumbs won't stick
into the egg
roll it round shake off any excess egg
wash and roll it into your breadcrumbs
you can use this same three-stage method
to breadcrumb anything you'd like from
chicken goujons and fish fillets to
vener schnitzel these are panko bread
crumbs Japanese white bread crumb so no
crust
you can experiment by adding flavors to
your breadcrumbs like parmesan herbs or
Citrus zest
I've always liked to push the actual
breadcrumbs into the sausage meat so it
gets that really nice golden brown and
stops any of the outside burning
once breadcrumbed lower the eggs
carefully into a four centimeter deep
bath of hot vegetable oil for 10 to 12
minutes
the eggs are actually cooked soft and
running the center so the objective is
just to cook the sausage meat and the
black pudding
that's great doesn't it the land
grenades
there's something so magical about a
scotch egg on a picnic because it's like
this little mini breakfast
beautiful
drain them onto the paper roll them
around
just to get off any excess oil and then
to transport them
some grease with paper
that for me is the perfect start to the
fishing trip there's no wonder I never
catch any fish
because I'm always too busy eating my
Scotch eggs
[Music]
My ultimate black pudding lace Scotch
eggs an irresistibly delicious picnic
breakfast
[Music]
coming up more on my ultimate picnic
dishes but first here's a closer look at
some of the key ingredients you'll need
to make them
for my picnic tea I'll be using prawns
from a beautiful translucent blue to
silver gray when raw turning to Pink
when cooked the sweet firm meaty flesh
of prawns is hugely popular across the
globe
smaller prawns are likely to be fished
from cold Waters of the Arctic they are
mostly sold cooked and are best served
cold
large types such as tiger and King
prawns tend to be farmed in warmer
Waters and can be bought raw or cooked
Parma ham is only produced in the Palmer
region of Northern Italy
made from the hind leg of the pig its
unique nutty flavor is said to be
achieved by adding parmesan whey to the
pig's slops
modern curin takes at least a year and
still follows age-old Traditions the
perfect cure is achieved with nothing
but sea salt and the tender loving care
of the master Salter
I'll be using this delicious sweet soft
ham in my giant picnic lunch sandwich
[Music]
terms of flavor per gram and Turbo's
pack a mighty punch
these small salt water oily fish are
incredible cooked whole
cured and tinned these versatile Little
Wonders are a must-have store-covered
ingredient
save the best quality ones for cold
dishes like nisoise salad or an amazing
anchovy butter
I'll be using these small fry with
attitude and a simple but Punchy picnic
dip
the key to Great picnic recipes is they
have to be practical as well as
delicious
my next two dishes are brilliant
Travelers and guaranteed to arrive at
the picnic looking and tasting just as
good as when they were packed for my
perfect picnic lunch a grated carrot
cumin and orange salad
and a spectacular sandwich based on a
classic from Southern France
pan Banya this is a picnic sandwich with
a Twist but the secret is in the layers
I'm gonna make a delicious tapana a
puree of Olives seasoned with capers and
anchovies
a nice tablespoon of extra virgin olive
oil
garlic in a little teaspoon of red wine
vinegar that just sort of zaps up the
flavor
quite like leaving it nice and chunky it
tastes better and feels richer I much
prefer spreading a smooth layer of
tapenade rather than using butter
now to prepare my first Mediterranean
sandwich filling I want nice long slices
of courgette courgettes can be a bland
vegetable season them nicely
once that Grill's nice and hot a
tablespoon of olive oil
the more color you put on those
courgettes the more flavor
while my griddle courgette's cool I can
prepare the bread this is a stunning
beautiful country loaf but we're not
going to slice it I'm just going to cut
the top off because I'm assembling a
picnic sandwich basket
and then an inch from the crust and go
around
scoop out a nice Large Hollow don't
waste this bread put that out it's dry
it makes the most amazing bread crumbs
the secret now is filling that cavity
with all those wonderful Mediterranean
flavors I'm going to leave them to sort
of sit and marinate lightly season the
inside of the loaf
drizzle of olive oil
line for that wonderful tapenade and
spread it generously
because the groundworking starts to set
the tone for the flavors that we're
incorporating
traditionally the main protein in pan
banyat would be tuna I'm sticking with
the med but replacing the fish with some
of my family's Italian favorites
Parma ham and start lining my sandwich
on the center
every time I add another ingredient it's
just another stunning layer of texture
and flavor but what I'm thinking about
is what actually complements
the next layer mozzarella a little spoon
of my tapenade
we've got the most amazing Aquila pepper
so we've got a nice Smoky Barbecue
flavor open them up and lay them
on top next layer is wonderful grilled
courgettes
on top of that some blush tomatoes
concentrated but really chewy and
delicious and each time lightly press
them down
creamy mozzarella again
finely peppers
push that down not too firm
fold in
seal that with your TAP a knife
almost like a little glue now lid on
to seal all that flavor in there
and not only travels well but actually
tastes delicious
that is one stunning
picnic sandwich
next a brilliant picnic salad that's
just as robust as your pan Banya carrot
and cumin and orange perfect combination
again travels brilliantly
it doesn't Wilt it doesn't disintegrate
orange zest
[Music]
squeeze the orange over
sunflower seeds a bit of crunch in there
pumpkin seeds again another bite
next a hint of spice toasted cumin seeds
ground with the help of a little coarse
sea salt
it's a nice fine powder
now for the dressing tablespoon of Dijon
mustard tablespoon of honey
half a tablespoon of white wine vinegar
and then a nice glug
of olive oil
fresh mint
and coriander the minute you start
picking fresh herbs all that flavor
comes out a nice mix
delicious vinaigrette mix that in
give enough dressing
bind it together excite the palate not
drown it if it was a leaf salad then I'd
take the dressing separately but because
this is a robust root vegetable it can
sustain being dressed now
and eaten in two hours time
sweet spicy fragrant company asked much
more from a carrot can you beautiful
[Music]
just when you're guests think that
you're
cutting up a delicious
country loaf
[Music]
look at that baby wow and who would not
want to join you on a picnic with a
sandwich like that
my ultimate picnic lunch to surprise and
impress pan Banya bursting with Rich
Sunshine flavors and serve with a
refreshingly zingy carrot cumin and
orange salad
[Music]
My ultimate picnic keeps it simple with
dishes that all work brilliantly well
together and that's one of the secrets
you have to treat a picnic like a
celebration meal make sure you've got a
stunning selection and a great balance
of taste and textures but above all make
sure it's fun I've saved my three most
indulgent dishes for a tea time picnic
treat a stunning prawn of cucumber salad
with a spicy yogurt dressing a Simply
Delicious anchovy dip
and a sticky chocolate fridge cake that
won't fail to revive a flagging family
until he's Keen to get in on the action
what are your favorites a marshmallow
and peanut fridge cake
perfect for a picnic first things first
we have to slowly melt the chocolate
[Music]
sounds good
I'm gonna break up the chocolate
right in there next butter goes in
a couple tablespoons of golden syrup
it's so good if we melt chocolate too
quickly it starts to separate and
destroy
the best and safest way to melt
chocolate is always use a Banbury but
I'm going to keep a really close eye on
mine and heat it over a super low heat
this stunning little cake has your
favorites in there our digestics yeah
put your hands in there and give them
like that one at a time ago
Crush what's the one thing that you love
about a picnic
I love eating outside especially on a
nice summery day not so much in the
winter there no
that's going to be the crunchy part of
our fridge cake and it's called a fridge
cake because it can sit in the fridge or
you can freeze it now peanuts in please
use it without peanuts if you're
allergic to peanuts oh you can do yeah
definitely no why are these little
babies and berries cranberries
from there
my favorite okay
they're so bright aren't they why do you
love marshmallows so much because
they're so squidgy all right give that a
nice mix up
chocolate is melting nicely okay I want
you to pour that in and I'll mix it nice
and gently slowly slowly slowly so
touch more please
isn't it good give that little mix with
Daddy please
I'm going to line the tray
so this is quite easy to make because um
you don't have to bake it mm-hmm you
just set it yeah I want you to start
pushing it into the corners please with
your fingers just laying it out nice and
flat
it's all nice and marshmallow
marshmallow I need to get the spatula
okay and look
how delicious does that look really
delicious if I can eat it right now like
I couldn't because it's not set
so we're not sets Okay it'll go nice and
firm and then we can cut it into little
bars little squares
triangles triangles
[Music]
for the important part of pushing it
down is that we can slice it and the
more we push the thinner we can slice
okay
[Music]
fridge cake done now I'm gonna make the
most amazing anchovy dip with vegetables
and bread
first cut slices of baguette and bake in
the oven at 180 degrees C for six
minutes or until crisp
meanwhile roughly chopped garlic and
shallots and add to a food processor
along with a tin of good quality
anchovies
sprinkle in some pitted black olives
flat leaf parsley and drizzle in the
reserved anchovy oil and a little olive
oil
Blitz to a paste and add pepper then
decant into a jar ready to transport
serve with a handful of fresh baby
carrots peppery radishes and your crisp
baguette toast
anchovy dip a portable and deliciously
palatable Alfresco treat
[Music]
now a spicy chili yogurt dressing with a
prawn salad first things first I'd like
you to make the dressing
fish sauce
it doesn't really smell like fishes so
one and a half tablespoons of fish sauce
two chili
I like this especially if you have it on
the side of the Palm
little teaspoon of sugar
oh that's it good
so four tablespoons of yogurt
three
foreign
[Music]
that sounds like my tummy
only sometimes only sometimes thank you
for that
it gives you the first time you have is
like a little thingy it's fresh
salty citrusy but delicious now cucumber
and the salad I want to get rid of all
the seeds so if you just nice and gently
peel your cucumber why do you feel it
can you not eat the skin on it you can
eat the skin but I want this salad to
taste of light and fresh you can use a
knife for this too though can't you you
can pay with a knife but a speed peeler
takes off the slices nice and thinly so
much quicker so much quicker that that's
why it's called a speed peeler
looks bare now it looks a bit naked it
does look a bit naked doesn't it now you
get your spoon you see what happens a
teaspoon just takes out all those seeds
so whilst it sits in the dish
it doesn't make the salad get all soft
because that cucumber is nice and
crunchy
[Music]
that's really good
it's always going to protect if you put
that little finger out This Little Piggy
boom comes off I wanted to tell you
about Daddy's knuckle that's the first
place you cut off
all the time there you go
the next addition to our prawn salad is
firm juicy baby gem lettuce
lettuce and a half what about the butt
the butts
keeping the butts on for now so when I
slice it it stays together
[Music]
a little bit there we don't use it okay
when you prepare that is for picnic you
never slice it too thinly okay otherwise
it Wills it's good prawns are ready
your tummy sauce is ready your dressing
is ready take the lid off
the trick is
you dress
the bottom of your dish because I'm
gonna put the prawns on here to protect
the lettuce get your cucumber
I put my cucumber on and then finally
that is
okay
now the seller's not going to go soft
why is that because it's not that it's
not straight onto the dressing that's
right what happens is we wrap this now
and then we get to our picnic drizzle
the sauce on top we mix it up we've got
the dressing on the bottom of the
dressing on top
that's right
a little bit of Clem film do you know
the cling film trick I don't know the
club film trick yet pink film over the
top of the toilet
what you don't understand it when you're
my age
oh you've been my idea then well okay
salad in the fridge with a dressing
ready to go for a picnic
this is my ultimate picnic dinner feast
prawn and cucumber salad with a spicy
yogurt dressing
anchovy dip with crudites and the kids
favorite chocolate marshmallow and
peanut fridge cake you can eat these
wonderful picnic dishes in any
combination at any time of the day
breakfast lunch or dinner time
Holly Tilly ready guys I'm ready and if
you're going on a picnic with a crowd
ladies ready for a picnic
do the whole lot as an Alfresco feast
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]
today I'm putting together a fantastic
breakfast lunch and dinner with an
American flavor I've traveled throughout
the United States for my work and as
well as having some shockingly bad meals
over there I've also had some brilliant
ones and right now the U.S food scene is
really vibrant lots of new talented
young chefs incorporating new flavors
into the dishes and Reinventing American
Classics taking my cue from some of the
best this is my ultimate American Home
Cooking first up for breakfast my take
on a U.S Diner classic eggs baked with
crispy hash browns and Smoky sweet bacon
for lunch the mighty American Caesar
salad with brittle chicken breast and a
big bold dressing followed by peanut
butter and jam cookies to die for time
for a little drink and middle daughter
Holly joins me in the kitchen you put
yours in there I'll put mine here Dad
we're creating an American Feast with
barbecue style beef brisket crunchy like
coleslaw and spicy sweet potato wedges
this is my ultimate American food
breakfast lunch and dinner first up eggs
baked in hash browns
The Secret of a great hash brown
other potatoes I prefer using really
nice waxy potatoes they cook better but
more importantly
hold themselves together
we're not going to slice the onion all
the potatoes but we're actually going to
grate them the potatoes get really nice
and crispy I mean seriously crispy now
the onion
that way you get that nice balance of
that onion flavor running through every
little Shard of potato
[Music]
season with salt pepper olive oil and km
give that a really good mix through
squeeze
all that water out
and look at all that juice we squeeze
out there really important the more
liquid you remove the crispier your hash
browns will be
nice large pan put that on
CE the Pan's hot pour in a good glug of
olive oil
[Music]
that sound confirms
how important is to have your pan nice
and hot
so it seals
the grated potato onion together
so take the spoon
and just
Pat it down what we're trying to do now
is get it really nice and compact
going around the outside of the pan with
little flecks of butter you just slip
them down the back gently
and that gets the onions caramelized
here's a great tip for turning your hash
browns over quick and easy take a plate
place it on top and just
flip it over
and then slide it back in very quickly
you see the color
we've got on there now
got that nice crispy texture
of the potato I'm going to use the hash
brown as a bed for my baked eggs
cracking your eggs nice and gently just
a little sprinkling of the can
to make the eggs a little bit spicy then
into a preheated oven for six to eight
minutes meanwhile onto my bacon and I'm
giving it a classic American twist now
one thing I could never get my head
around when I first started eating lots
of American breakfast was the sweetness
from the bacon I've grown up to love
that combination of smoky sweet flavors
and it's so easy pan on and simply heat
olive oil brown sugar salt and pepper
and butter bacon in and as it Cooks it
becomes irresistibly caramelized and
golden brown Turf of gas
and my glazed bacon
it's absolutely ready beautiful
now my hash browns and baked eggs are
ready
beautiful just
keep your spatula underneath there
onto your plate and that bacon sets
beautifully on top of the baked eggs and
that hash brown underneath and
you can see why the best breakfast in
the world are always in America
this is an All-American superhero offer
breakfast eggs bacon hash browns with
glazed bacon
[Music]
next I'm showing you a fantastic
American inspired lunch and dinner
[Music]
to go to the US to buy the ingredients
here's a closer look at the key ones
first up it's beef brisket a cheap cut
from the breast of the cow
it's underused in the UK but loved by
American cousins and used for incredible
delicates like Pastrami and succulent
salt beef
the key to beef brisket is to cook it
low and slow to make it tender and I've
got a delicious barbecue style recipe
for dinner
[Music]
next sweet potatoes as American as apple
pie
sometimes called yams in the USA they're
native to the tropical Americans they
cook quicker than standard potatoes
they're packed with nutrients and have a
fantastic sweet flavor whether you mash
them bake them or roast them but I
really love the simple sweet potato
wedges I'm making for dinner
[Music]
the ultimate American staple has to be
peanut butter and more than half the
peanuts grown in the U.S are used to
make it
I love it both crunchy or smooth and not
just spread on bread it's fantastic and
savory sauces like Satay or even in
desserts like the peanut butter and jam
cookies I'm making for lunch
the main course will be a crispy Big
Caesar salad but the first job are my
peanut butter and jam cookies
[Music]
start with the cookie dough simply
combine muscovado sugar peanut butter
and butter until light and fluffy
then add your egg a splash of milk
vanilla seeds and beat again until
smooth
sift together salt baking powder and
flour
[Music]
and mix until thoroughly combined
in floured hands roll the cookie dough
into golf ball sizes flatten and create
an indent with your finger fill with
half jam and half peanut butter
place the cookies on a tray lined with
baking paper and bake in a preheated
oven for 10 to 12 minutes
before serving
[Music]
next job main course and my take on an
iconic American salad first made almost
a century ago Caesar salad is definitely
a classic but the trick to keeping
dishes like this modern and relevant is
to tweak them but not lose what made
them brilliant in the first place here's
my version for the ultimate American
lunch my first twist is in the dressing
for me the most important part of the
Caesar salad is that dressing
Rich creamy slightly spicy
Begin by making a basic mayonnaise
start off with the egg yolks in just
a little spoon Dijon and then a little
splash of red wine vinegar
start whisking
once you've got that nice slightly
thickened texture
drizzle in your olive oil
should fall through
your whisk it's like a nice thick
double cream texture
beautiful
now take the Mayo to another level with
Anchovies and crushed garlic now chop up
the anchovies and the garlic together
so we almost want that to be like a
really nice
puree then grated Parmesan lemon juice
that will make the dressing
citrusy
lighter in color and then a little
splash of water
and
now
all of a sudden it transforms that
mayonnaise into an amazing
delicious
light dressing
nice
job the croutons and I like using crusty
bread for extra Crunch and just dice up
your bread season with salt and pepper
then add to a hot pan with olive oil and
Fry give that a really nice toss as the
croutons start to turn golden simply
great on a generous amount of Parmesan
cheese keep them rolling around stop
them from sticking together think of
that really nice cheesy delicious
Crouton and now they're out
now for the fun job assembling the
Caesar salad starting with Romaine
lettuce
and don't slice the lettuce too thinly
a squeeze of lemon on with half of that
gutsy anchovy Mayo dressing
saving some to coat your chicken later
then sprinkle half your croutons
look at that a really nice mix
salad in it's all beautifully dressed
add the remaining croutons and finish
with a good grating of Parmesan cheese
that for me is a perfect season salad
however I'm going to take it to another
level and grill a stunning
to breast start by preheating your
griddle pan then butterfly your chicken
breast simply slice from the thin end
towards the thick bit of the breast put
the knife to the work and literally just
open up
now that's how we butterfly a chicken
breast so therefore it will cook twice
as quick and just nice and moist in the
center
season the chicken on both sides with
salt and ground pepper lay your chicken
breast onto the grill
[Music]
never oil the grill until you're
absolutely ready to cook your chicken
now turn them over
useful
cook for three to four minutes on each
side until the chicken's got those
lovely Stripes from The Griddle which
adds a gorgeous Smoky flavor whilst they
rest spoon over some of the remaining
anchovy dressing
the chicken cools down the flavor the
seasoning of the anchovy the garlic and
the parmesan seeps into that chicken
slice the chicken into strips
wow
I serve the chicken warm in a separate
Bowl so it doesn't Wilt the salad spoon
the dressing
finish that with a little touch of
dressing
an American classic
I think one of the most popular sellers
anywhere in the world but it's still the
most delicious
[Music]
when it comes to lunch this really is an
American Dream a delicious Caesar salad
and succulent Golden Griddle chicken
with peanut butter and jam cookies for
dessert
when it comes to cooking techniques
barbecue is virtually a religion in
America especially in the southern
states down there the real barbecue Pros
use big open fire pits to get huge
joints of meat super succulent and
fantastically perfume with smoke and
spice so my ultimate American dinner has
to include an amazing melt-in-the-mouth
barbecue beef but I'm doing it the easy
way cooked in the oven low and slow
my family I spent a lot of time in the
US and they love American food
joining me in the kitchen today is
Jack's twin sister Holly we're creating
barbecue style beef brisket with crunchy
coleslaw and sweet potato wedges which
will be right up her Street
Holly
now
you love barbecues right
so you're gonna help me barbecue this
delicious piece of brisket brisket
look at it beautiful it was a very tough
cut of meat so it needs to be cooked
slowly so it gets really nice and tender
barbecuing it outside we're going to
actually put the barbecue flavor on
there but we're going to cook it in the
oven okay so mustard powder okay here we
have some celery seed next
a little bit of salt in there
okay what's this here cumin two again
nice good now this one
cayenne pepper I'll see right right two
teaspoons of that in there as well
because now what I want you to do
fresh pepper on there
I'll give that a little mix roll up your
little sleeves and then
I want you
to rub
all that spice into the brisket
almost like you're massaging it in there
good girl come on holes get your hands
nice and flat on there good girl
now that's nice and coated okay
in the spice SO gas on roasting tray on
what we've got to do now with all those
spices is sear them in a couple of
tablespoons of olive oil into the tray
all done okay that's getting nice and
hot now you get your brisket
and all that spice
throw that in there nicely okay so now
we'll start coloring it
as you start to sear in you smell those
spices yep all that spice left on the
plate we're gonna use yeah
I want you to get the onions
nice and carefully slice them down not
too thin
but just like you're chopping them take
your time
foreign
spices now
good girl thank you
damn Holly
was homework that bad no the onions oh
no don't rub your eyes don't rub your
eyes
[Music]
we've got the color
look on the brisket okay yeah
yeah take that out literally for 30
seconds okay onions into the tray please
nice
you see it started to smell slightly
barbecuing already give that a little
stir
nice now one nice tablespoon of brown
sugar
what does brown sugar do that so the
brown sugar you're gonna start
caramelizing the onions
right from there my Bailey's in please
good girl yes please right we'll take
over
that tray is very very hot
a tablespoon of tomato puree roast that
off at the bottom of the tray to really
rub it in amongst the onions good girl
now look at the color of those onions
right now time for a little drink
for the brisket
okay one bottle of beer in please so you
go in you put yours in there I'll put
mine here good health to you and your
brisket good health
bring that to the ball
okay now this is where it gets really
exciting I want you to lift the brisket
up and put it on top of the onions and
she goes
good girl
and then I want you to pour the stock
all the way around please I'm using beef
stock but it will work with chicken
stock or even vegetable stock
once the stock has come to the boil
cover tightly with foil and just pinch
in the ends
turn that down and then you just twist
all the way
so that's nice and tight that's the hard
work done thank you
simply pop it in the oven for three and
a half hours and as it Cooks you can get
on with the side dishes
first job sweet potato wedges with some
serious flavor
start by making a spice mix in a dry pan
toast coriander seeds until beautifully
aromatic
then put them in a pestle and mortar add
salt and grind
[Music]
next smoke paprika dried oregano cayenne
pepper and mix spice mix done now simply
cut your sweet potatoes into wedges toss
an olive oil and thoroughly cover with
the spice mix
onto a baking tray and into a preheated
oven for 30 minutes turning halfway
irresistible sweet potato wedgies are
ready now to finish off my beef
see that smell just sort of travels
everywhere
oh
now look at that so we can leave that to
rest what does resting mean resting
means where you've cooked a joint and
you just leave it to relax so it'll make
the meat so much more tender okay right
coleslaw traditionally you would mix
slaw with what mayonnaise that's right
mayonnaise this time we're gonna do it a
little different so I'd like to put the
yogurt into the bowl for me
place all of it I'll start slicing the
white cabbage
and the red cabbage now from there a
nice tablespoon
of mustard in there please give that a
nice mix up
nice little touch of salt and pepper
okay now
a little cider vinegar so a little
splash of cider vinegar in there okay as
I shred this okay I'd like you please
then to get the
red cabbage and just open up into that
and mix it in at the same time and then
you fold that in there as I start
shredding
see how it's coming together yeah
right that's all the red cabbage now for
the white
so you've got that nice vinegary
tartness for the slaw and the yogurt
keeps it nice and fresh
nice little bit in
one more little thing
so
it was a nice
chopped fresh chives in there and that
will give it this nice light
onion flavor
so chives in
how's that now taste it with the chives
in there
delicious so
like you
to fill up the bowl I'm going to very
carefully lift out my brisket how come
junk it's been in the oven
for nearly three and a half hours so
it's been cooked slowly
that sits on there oh my goodness me let
me just show you what this looks like
and start slicing it and see how soft
look at that
and here's the thing about helping daddy
cook
here's the perk
you get to taste it first before anybody
that is so good that
taste
delicious see all that wonderful flavor
in there last job is to create an
incredibly quick and delicious sauce
on and reduce the spicy juices and
onions the beef cooked in then add
inside of vinegar and you add a
brilliant Tangy barbecue sauce
smells nice
brisket
now the rest of it
should go in the gravy pot
that's a really nice rich
spicy
barbecue
onion gravy
that my darling is the perfect way
to serve brisket right you ready
if you carry
the sweet potato for me I've got the
brisk in WoW
let's go Donnie well done by the way
thank you this is a real American Beauty
gorgeous low and slow cooked barbecue
beef brisket with three potato wedges
and yogurt coleslaw
Megan Jack hi Tilly big deep Smoky
flavors that bring the taste of the
American South to your kitchen
who'd like some coleslaw I'd love
and who'd like some gravy thank you but
it's spicy and slightly barbecuing how's
the brisket really good
it's amazing
with the gravy
and what do you think
is that
I'm pretty good you think so yeah if
you're not as good as mine but I can
feel
a lot of competition
in amongst the Ramsey girls good job
thank you there are loads more great
home cooking recipes on my app cook with
me you can find it in the App Store good
luck